[موسيقى]
أحب أن أكون في الطبيعة في
جميع أنحاء لندن ، فهناك الآلاف من
المنتزهات مثل هذه التي بها
مظلة شجرة جميلة فقط وأنا أحب الانحناء
، فالفرع هو الضوء المرقط الذي
يمر عبر الأشجار هناك صوت
الرياح التي تمر عبر الأغصان.  أنا دان
رافين إليسون وأنا أعمل على جعل
لندن مدينة منتزهات وطنية عندما
يفكر معظم الناس في المتنزهات الوطنية التي
يفكرون فيها في الصحاري أو الغابات المطيرة أو
الجبال أو أو مورلاند ، لكنني
استكشفت جميع المتنزهات الوطنية في المملكة
المتحدة ولاحظت ذلك  ربما يكون هناك شيء
مفقود وهذه منطقة حضرية رئيسية
نشارك فيها هذه المدينة مع 15000
نوع آخر من الحيوانات البرية ولا أعتقد
أن قيمة الحياة الحضرية أقل من
ذلك ، ولا أعتقد أن قيمة الثعلب الأحمر الحضري
أقل مما تعرفه  ثعلب القطب الشمالي
أو ثعلب الصحراء ، إنه مجرد ثعلب أحمر
أعتقد أن الناس يستيقظون على حقيقة
أننا بحاجة إلى علاقة أفضل
مع الطبيعة من أجل صحتنا ورفاهيتنا من
أجل صحة
ورفاهية البرية  سكان العالم
لكننا نحتاج أيضًا إلى علاقة أفضل
بالطبيعة من أجل صحة
مدننا وقدرتها على الصمود للتعامل مع
تغير المناخ ، لقد بدأت الحملة
لجعل لندن مدينة منتزه وطني
منذ خمس سنوات الآن وعندما بدأت ،
أعتقد أن معظم الناس  اعتقدت
أنني مجنونة تمامًا ولكن يسعدني
أن أشارككم أنه بعد كل هذا العمل ،
سيتم إطلاق لندن
كأول مدينة منتزهات وطنية في العالم في يوليو 2019